بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله القابل
فلم تقتلوهم ولكن الله قتلهم وما رميت اد
رميت ولكن الله ربى سرايا القدس في لواء
خان يونس وفي ظل معركه طوفان الاقصى
المباركه واستبسال وقتالها للعدو في جميع
المحاور تمكن مجاهدينا بحول الله وعونه
وتوفيقه واثناء عمليه تسلل لهم في احدى
محاور تقدم العدو في جنوب غرب لواء خان
يونس السيطره على طائره مسيره العدو من
نوع كت كارتر ماترس 30 حيث حاولت الاطباق
على المجموعه المتسلله ولكن وبحمد الله
وتوفيقه وكرمه على مجاهدينا تمكن مجاهدينا
من استهداف هذه الطائره والتعامل معها
والسيطره عليها والحصول على معلومات هامه
وخزن بداخلها وعوده مجاهدينا وبحمد الله
الى قواعدهم بسلام ترعاهم رعايه الله وح
حفظه ومن هنا نؤكد من جديد نحن في صرايا
القدس لهذا العدو المجرم ان ارضنا وبحر و
سماؤنا محرم على هذا العدو والله مولانا
ولا مولا
لهم
y